Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological wellbeing practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences people have prior to applying for the doctorate. And it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical
你好，我叫贝丝，是来自纽卡斯尔的一名心理健康从业者。我只想对《临床心理学家集体》这本书的撰稿人表示最诚挚的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾经非常怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床
psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot, so the biggest thank you ever. What if the key to your psychology career isn't about ticking all the usual boxes, but rewriting the script entirely? In today's episode, I'm joined by Jack Lowe, who shares how he carved out a meaningful psychology path without ever landing an assistant psychologist role. From setbacks to speaking gigs, this one is for anyone wondering if there's still a way in for them, even if it doesn't look like the traditional route.
心理学博士学位，但这本书确实给了我所需要的自信，让我决定试一试，所以真的非常感谢。如果你的心理学职业生涯的关键不在于满足所有常规条件，而是彻底改写剧本呢？在今天的节目中，杰克·洛（Jack Lowe）将加入我的行列，他将分享自己如何在从未获得助理心理学家职位的情况下，开辟出一条有意义的心理学道路。从挫折到演讲机会，这一集是为那些想知道自己是否还有机会进入这个领域，即使它看起来不像传统路线的人准备的。
Hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now I did take quite a traditional route, but I do feel like I've been able to be reflective and curious and make the most of roles that haven't seemed that relevant at the time and that is something that I am speaking with Jack about today who is an expert in this and we've got lots of interesting theory, concepts, kind of models, ways of working and this is a really lovely episode.
希望你觉得这非常有帮助。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我确实走了一条相当传统的路线，但我确实觉得我能够进行反思和保持好奇心，并充分利用那些当时看起来并不相关的角色，这也是我今天与杰克讨论的内容，他是这方面的专家，我们有很多有趣的理论、概念、模型、工作方式，这一集真的很棒。
Hope you find it really useful. I'll catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Jack Lowe. Hi Jack, welcome along. Hi, it's great to be here today. Thank you for having me. Thank you for being here and thank you for pitching the episode to me because actually I really love it when people come up with kind of diverse angles for talking about psychology and you know their passion and why it matters to them. So yeah tell us a bit about what people might get from today please Jack. Yeah I think from today is I really want to kind of try and frame my experience. I've only recently discovered I'm quite an unconventional, untraditional student.
希望你觉得它真的很有用。我们稍后见。你好，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾杰克·洛。你好杰克，欢迎来到这里。你好，很高兴今天能来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。谢谢你的到来，也谢谢你向我推荐这一集，因为实际上我真的很喜欢人们提出各种不同的角度来谈论心理学，你知道他们的热情以及为什么这对他们很重要。所以，杰克，请告诉我们大家今天能从中学到什么。是的，我想今天我真的想尝试构建我的经验。我最近才发现我是一个非常规、非传统的学生。
My career has definitely followed that as well, working very entry-level roles to customer service. I've really had to get creative with how I can make the most out of these roles to make them psychologically informed to get to where I am now. I'm looking to work for a large mental health charity. I'm looking to work as a regional manager with that. I'm also now doing a masters, but it's not always been a straightforward start. There's been a lot of redos, some failings and having to really learn from that which we really want to try and promote today for you know students and other aspiring psychologists.
我的职业生涯也绝对遵循了这一点，从客户服务的入门级工作做起。我真的必须发挥创造力，充分利用这些角色，使它们具有心理学意义，从而达到我现在的水平。我正在寻找一家大型心理健康慈善机构的工作。我正在寻求担任该机构的区域经理。我现在也在攻读硕士学位，但起步并不总是那么顺利。经历了很多重做、一些失败，并且必须真正从中学习，我们今天真的很想为学生和其他有抱负的心理学家推广这一点。
Amazing. So now we know what we're going to gonna get let's have a little bit of an overview about who we're gonna get it from so tell us a bit about yourself Jack. Yeah absolutely so obviously my name is Jack Lowe I'm born and based in Blackpool and I did I think some of my takeaways is that I've done university after like three false attempts I've had a failing I've had a drop that I've kind of done university after like three false attempts. I've had a failing, I've had a drop out, I've had a deferred, similar with sixth form as well. So my relationship with education has always been a little bit complex. And then I've kind of returned as an adult learner, same with building my career. So for the longest part, I started off in tele sales
太棒了。既然我们知道我们将要得到什么，让我们简单了解一下我们将从谁那里得到它，所以杰克，请介绍一下你自己。好的，没问题，我叫杰克·洛，我在布莱克浦出生并居住。我想我的一些收获是，我在三次失败的尝试后才完成了大学学业，我经历过失败，经历过退学，经历过延期，高中阶段也类似。所以我与教育的关系一直有点复杂。然后我以成年学习者的身份回归，建立我的职业生涯也是如此。所以很长一段时间里，我从电话销售开始
and then kind of went into customer service It was all these kind of entry-level roles and I just got to a point where I thought I need to get a little bit more serious about developing my career But I also have bills to pay I need to do what I need to do now So what can I do to really make the most of that and now as I'm doing my masters, you know I've got a definition for that I've got a term for it that we talk about around job crafting so what we can do to make that role you know fulfilling for us and get us to our long-term goals so really get a bit creative with it.
然后进入了客户服务领域。这些都是入门级的角色，我到了一个地步，觉得我需要更认真地对待职业发展。但我也有账单要付，我必须做我现在需要做的事情，那么我能做些什么来真正充分利用这一点呢？现在我正在攻读硕士学位，你知道我对此有一个定义，我们称之为“工作塑造”（job crafting），即我们可以做些什么来让那个角色对我们来说是充实的，并让我们实现长期目标，所以真的要发挥一点创造力。
Amazing tell us a bit more about job crafting then. So job crafting is the term it can be done across different ways there's a few little breakdowns from it whether it's cognitive crafting so the way we think about our role very similar for those that are looking more at maybe mental health or clinical psychology around that kind of CBT what are my thought patterns around this and I know there's been several studies around people assessing their kind of well-being their mood and job satisfaction my thought patterns around this. And I know there's been several studies around people assessing their kind of wellbeing, their mood and job satisfaction based on how they think about their role, whether they view it positively, whether they view it negatively or whether
太棒了，那请多讲讲“工作塑造”。所以“工作塑造”是一个术语，可以通过不同的方式完成，它有几个小分类，无论是认知塑造，即我们思考角色的方式，这对于那些更多关注心理健康或临床心理学的人来说非常相似，围绕那种认知行为疗法（CBT），我对此的想法模式是什么？我知道已经有几项研究围绕人们评估他们的幸福感、情绪和工作满意度，我对此的想法模式是什么。我知道已经有几项研究围绕人们评估他们的幸福感、情绪和工作满意度，基于他们如何看待自己的角色，他们是积极看待，消极看待，还是
they view it as being important. So whether you're someone that is just cleaning the floors or keeping this hospital safe and sanitary to benefit people. And having that kind of difference in thinking pattern has a massive effect. But then also the more practical kind of task crafting. So what kind of tasks do I do in my day to day? What is it in my job description? And what is it I actually want to do that I'm passionate about that fulfills me, that challenges me? And I definitely think that's something I've been doing without knowing the term over the last
他们认为这很重要。所以，无论你是一个只是打扫地板，还是为了造福他人而保持医院安全卫生的人。这种思维模式的差异会产生巨大的影响。但还有更实际的“任务塑造”。那么我在日常工作中做什么任务？我的职位描述里有什么？我真正想做的是什么，我对此充满热情，能满足我，挑战我？我绝对认为这是我过去几年在不知道这个术语的情况下一直在做的事情，为了将心理学带入一个角色，即使它不是像助理心理学家（AP）那样的传统心理学角色。绝对是这样。而且我认为这确实引起了我的共鸣。实际上，我非常早期的播客节目之一就是关于如何充分利用非心理学角色来加强和推进你的职业生涯。而且我认为这可能是因为它发布时间较早，它是下载量最高的剧集之一。但因为它确实很重要，你知道，我们在旅途中学到的东西确实很重要。我想知道“工作塑造”这个概念
couple of years to really bring psychology to a role, even though it's not a traditional psychology role like an AP. Definitely. And I think that's something that really resonates with me. Actually, one of my very early podcast episodes is about making the most of kind of non-psychology roles to still strengthen and advance your career. And I think that's probably because of its age, it's one of the most downloaded episodes as well. But because it does matter, you know, what we learn along the journey does matter. And I wonder whether the concept of job crafting
也许你和我之前在不知道它叫什么的时候就已经在做了，这是否也有助于我们不至于精疲力竭，因为它感觉就像你有自己的小使命，你自己的某种目标。但我猜一旦你觉得你已经达到了饱和点，你可能会冒着“无聊透顶”（bore out）的风险，那时你就已经达到了你可以从中获得的极限
that perhaps you and I have been doing before knowing what it was called maybe helps us to maybe not burn out as well, because it feels like you've got your own little sort of mission, your own kind of purpose. But I guess once you feel like you've reached saturation point, you might then risk bore out and it's then that you've kind of you've reached the limit of what you can gain
，也许这表明是时候离开了。100%，我认为这取决于个人的核心工作是什么，以及他们能在多大程度上突破一些界限。我知道在我的一些所谓的入门级职位或呼叫中心，你在能做的事情上受到很大限制。所以你确实必须发挥一点创造力来推销其他额外职责。但即使是那些事情，嗯，有时为了得到你可能需要的东西，会有一些牺牲。所以我知道过去我也做过志愿者工作，这是我工作时间之外的补充，以满足我想要的那些需求，除此之外我还
from that and maybe that's an indication that it's time to move on. 100% and I think it would be down to the individual what their core job is and maybe how far they can push some of the boundaries. I know in some of my say more entry-level positions or in call centres, you are very restricted to what you can do. So you do have to be a little bit creative to market other additional duties. But even things, well there's sometimes a little bit of a sacrifice to get what you may need. So I know in the past I've done volunteering work as well, it's an addition to my hours to fulfill those needs that I wanted alongside that I've
在英国心理学会（BPS）做过志愿者，并参加了他们的委员会。所以同样，为了建立经验和兴趣，并稍微尝试一下我真正喜欢做什么？我喜欢写内容吗？我喜欢直接支持人们吗？稍微尝试一下，而不是只关注特定职位的最终目的地。是的，绝对是这样，而且我知道我以前也在呼叫中心工作过，想到我们作为本科学习的结果所拥有的技能，实际上可能意味着我们也是该服务的资产，我们可以参与思考数据，思考
also volunteered with the BPS and sat on their committee. So again, to build experience and interest and have a little play around with what do I actually enjoy doing? Do I enjoy writing content? Do I enjoy supporting people directly and have a little play around with it, rather than just focusing on the kind of end destination of a particular job role. Yeah absolutely and I know I've worked in call centre as well before and thinking about actually the skills that we've got perhaps as a result of doing our undergrad that actually might mean that we are an asset to the service as well that we can kind of get involved with thinking about data thinking about
一些人员管理以及人们如何很好地协同工作，以及生产力和主动性，正如乔·格雷（Joe Gray）博士最近告诉我们的那样。是的，对我来说，我发现我被允许少做一点我被雇佣去做的工作，多做一点培养与经理关系的工作，去做其他支持团队运作的工作，但也减少了我不得不整天不停地接听电话的压力。100%，我知道在我工作的最后两个呼叫中心，我这样做的方式是通过心理健康急救员。所以在一个呼叫中心，我是客户服务人员。我们接听人们的电话，我们实际上在监督
some of the kind of people management and the way that people work really well together and kind of productivity and proactivity as kind of Dr Joe Gray was telling us about recently. And yeah, for me, I found I was getting permission to do a little bit less of the work I was paid for and a little bit more of kind of cultivating the relationship with my manager to do other jobs that support the functioning of the team but also then reduce the pressure for me having to answer the calls relentlessly all day. 100% I know in the last two call centres I worked in the way I did it was through mental health first aiders. So in one of the call centres I was customer service. We were taking calls from people, we were actually overseeing
他们的工资单。所以如果他们的工资有问题，如果中心的人有考勤表问题，我们处理付款，人们就会生气。你知道，他们有周末，他们有账单，他们有家庭。我们会让他们处于非常高的情绪状态。而且我们一直都有人因为生病、心理健康挣扎、职场欺凌等原因请假。所以这就是我看到机会的地方，我说，好吧，实际上，我想成为一名心理健康急救员。我们公司已经有这样的人了，但他们通常是我们的HR会计，而不是面对客户的人。所以我说，这就是为什么它会有好处。我们都为这些电话而挣扎，它给了我一项技能，它是
their payroll. So we would get people angry if there was an issue with their wages, if the people on the centre of the timesheet and we were processing payment. You know, they've got a weekend, they've got bills, they've got family. We'd get them in, you know, really high emotional states. And all, all times that we'd have people going off work for sickness, struggling with their mental health, workplace bullying, whatever it may be. So that's where I kind of saw an opportunity and said, well, actually, I'd like to be a mental first aider. We had them in the company already, but they typically were kind of our HR accountants and not people customer facing. So I said, this is why it will be a benefit. We all struggle with these calls, it gives me a skill, it's
我充满热情的事情。这是一个显而易见的选择，对每个人都有利。所以我就是这么做的。我真的很喜欢那样，因为它允许我使用仍然相关的不同技能。所以如果我想继续，这就是我所做的，我真的很喜欢那样，因为它允许我使用仍然相关的不同技能。所以如果我想继续进入助理心理学家（AP）或心理健康从业者（PWP）的角色，那就是在情绪状态下、在危机中与人交谈、试图支持他们、引导他们、表现出同理心和积极倾听，并在相当非传统的背景下利用这些技能的经验。在我工作的最后一个联络中心，我们没有任何心理健康急救员
something I'm passionate in. It's a you know, a bit of a no brainer, it suits everyone. So that was what I did. And I really enjoyed that because it allowed me to use different skills that were still relevant. So if I wanted to continue that was what I did and I really enjoyed that because it allowed me to use different skills that were still relevant. So if I wanted to continue going into a P role or a PWP, it's that experience of talking to people, you know, in an emotional state in a crisis, trying to support them, sound post, you know, empathetic and active listening and utilizing those skills in quite an untraditional context. And the last contact centre I worked in, we didn't have any mental health first aiders in
在呼叫中心。我们有一点分歧，因为有两栋楼。所以你有一栋楼是呼叫中心，然后另一栋楼是财务、学习与发展（L&D）、人力资源（HR）。所以我们有点被孤立了。我想，好吧，没人想和人力资源主管说话。让我再次成为一名心理健康急救员，把它作为你网络的一部分。然后现场就有人了。作为一名心理健康急救员，我非常受欢迎。想到这些人可能没有在马路对面的另一栋楼里寻求支持，这让我感到难过。所以任何听到这个的人，我绝对会鼓励，如果你
the call centre. We had a bit of a divide because there was two buildings. So you had one building call centre, then you had the other building that was all the finance, L&D, HR. So we were a little bit left alone. And I thought, well, nobody wants to speak to the head of HR. Let me again, become a mental health first aider, do it as part of your network. And then there's someone on the ground. And I was really popular as a mental health first aider. And it saddens me to think these people may not have reached out to support across the road in the other building. And so anyone listening to that I would definitely encourage that if you are
想更多地从事心理健康工作，更偏向临床或咨询心理学方面，如果你仍然在呼叫中心或酒店业等地方工作，在你的企业角色中，这是一个很好的方式，你可以获得一些经验，这是一个很好的方式，你可以尝试获得其中的一些技能和经验。绝对是这样，如果你能在你已经领取薪水或已经赚钱的工作岗位内完成它，那么这对你和访问该职业的其他人来说就更公平了，因为显然志愿和荣誉工作
wanting to work more with mental health, the more clinical or counselling psychology side, that's a good way you can get some experience in a non-traditional role, in your corporate role if you are still working in call centres or in hospitality or whatever it may be, that's a really good way you can try and gain some of those skills and experiences. Absolutely, and if you can get it done within your job role where you're already salaried or you're already earning money, then that's even more equitable for you and for others accessing the career as well because obviously voluntary and honorary work
有一大堆道德考量，但如果我们能将其融入其中，然后获得技能，即使我们在做纸面上不相关的工作，我们也能够真正证明我们合作过的这些关键临床群体，即使是在临床环境之外。所以当然，如果有人想考虑进入临床心理学，我们经常关注的四个核心群体是儿童、年轻人和家庭、
there's a whole heap of ethical considerations, but if we can kind of build that in and then get the skills, even when we're doing kind of on paper unrelated work, we're able to actually evidence these key kind of clinical groups that we've worked with, even outside of clinical settings. So of course, if someone was looking to think about coming into clinical psychology, the four core groups we'll often look at are children, young people and families,
工作年龄的成年人、老年人和有智力障碍的人。所以如果你能几乎成为你已经在做的工作中其中一个领域的“核心倡导者”。所以我知道，例如，我的一个朋友不是有抱负的心理学家，但在医疗诊所工作，非常喜欢并且以前曾与有智力障碍的人一起工作。所以实际上现在几乎成为了在她工作角色中做事情以真正支持有智力障碍的人的倡导者。这是一个非常好的“工作塑造”例子，无论你在做什么，是否有倡导者？你能成为那个倡导者吗？帮助服务运行得更好，这将帮助访问该服务的客户。它可能还有助于提升服务中其他人的技能，
working age adults, older adults, and people with intellectual disabilities. So if you're able to kind of almost become like a core champion in the work you're doing already for one of those areas. So I know for example one of my friends who's not an aspiring psych but works in a medical surgery really enjoys and has previously worked with people with intellectual disabilities. And so actually is now almost a champion for doing things within her work role to really support people with intellectual disabilities. And that's a really nice example of kind of job crafting that whatever you're doing, is there a champion? Could you be it? To help service run better, which will help the clients accessing the service. It potentially helps upskill other people in the service as well,
但有助于你证明你在该领域拥有真正的技能，并可能确定你可能需要支持该领域的未来培训。不知不觉中，你就在通往目标的道路上建立了这些基石。100%，这绝对是我很幸运能抓住的一些机会。在我目前的工作中，我是幸福网络的一部分，所以我一直在举办研讨会，我一直在应用心理学理论，我正在做用于发展心理资本的英雄（HERO）模型，即人们如何预防倦怠并提升自己。但同样，这非常非传统。它不一定是我的工作角色的一部分，但这是许多组织在公共和私营部门都会有的东西，提供倡导者角色和心理健康急救员，围绕幸福感或多样性、公平和包容性的事情，特别是在慈善机构中，
but helps you to evidence that you've got real skills in this area and to potentially identify future training you might need to support that. Before you know it, you're building those blocks on your way. 100% and it's definitely something I've been lucky I just kind of grasped some of the opportunities off. It's in my current role I'm part of a well-being network so I've been running workshops, I've been applying psychological theory, I was doing the hero model for developing psychological capital, so how people can prevent burnout and clit themselves. But again, that's very untraditional. It's not necessarily part of my job role, but it's something a lot of organisations will have both in public and private sector, offer champion roles and mental health first aiders, things around wellbeing or diversity diversity and inclusion and especially in charities as well,
还有许多共同生产小组。所以同样，所有与人们直接为了共同目标和成就而努力的实践经验，那里有一个目标，然后你也可以将你的理论应用到其中。太棒了。我不认为我们在播客上谈论过英雄（HERO）模型。杰克，你能多告诉我们一点吗？当然可以。我真的很喜欢英雄模型。我想部分原因是因为它有一个非常朗朗上口的标题。在我的研讨会上，我表达得相当尴尬，但我完全支持一点点俗气的“做你自己的英雄”。然后我谈到了英雄模型。所以对我来说这是一个很棒的部分。我想它是2006年由汉莎航空（Lufthansa）
a lot of the co-production groups as well. So again, all hands on experience with people directly going for, you know, a common goal and achievement, there's an objective there and then you can also apply your theory to that as well. Fabulous. I don't think we've spoken about the hero model on the podcast before. Are you able to tell us a little bit more about that, Jack? Absolutely. So I really enjoy the hero model. I think partially because it's got a very nice catchy title. In my workshop, I phrased it quite cringy, but I'm all here for a little bit of cheese of be your own hero. And then I talked about the hero model. So it was a wonderful segment for me. It was done by, I think it was, Lufthansa
塔（Tower）提出的。它完全围绕心理资本。即我们作为个人所拥有的资源，以确保我们处于某种韧性状态，我们有积极的幸福感，并且已经有很多关于它的研究，特别是在工作场所预防倦怠、工作满意度、生活满意度方面，而英雄（HERO）代表了我们可以做的事情，以建立希望（Hope）、自我效能（Self-efficacy）、韧性（Resilience）和乐观（Optimism）。所以我们可以做很多事情，我把它带入工作场所，关于我们作为个人可以做什么，以及我们可以在整个组织中系统地朝着这些原则工作。所以为希望可以做的事情，围绕目标设定的事情。所以心中有一个目标来保持
Tower, I think 2006. And it is all around psychological capital. So the resources we have as an individual to make sure we're kind of resilient, we've got positive wellbeing, and there's been loads of studies around it especially in the workplace on preventing burnout, job satisfaction, life satisfaction and the HERO stands for things that we can do to build hope, self-efficacy, resilience and optimism. So a lot of things that we can do and I bring it into the workplace of what we can do as an individual and what we can do, you know, systematically across the organisation working towards these kind of principles. So things we can do for hope, things around kind of goal setting. So having a goal in mind to keep
我们充满希望，也有那种成就感。自我效能感植根于我们对自己能力的自信程度。所以我尝试在培训方面向个人推广这一点，你知道，是什么让你对自己所做的事情感到自信？这很好地融入了那种韧性。所以无论我们是在以问题为导向还是以解决方案为导向的视角下看待事物，如果我们有正确的培训，我们也许能够做出更好的判断，我们可以
us hopeful and also that sense of achievement. Self-efficacy is rooted in how confident we are in our abilities. So I try and promote that as individuals around that training, you know, what is it to make you feel confident in what you do? That kind of bleeds quite nicely into that resilience. So whether we're looking at things in a kind of problem-focused orientation or solution-focused, and if we've got the correct kind of training with that, we might be able to make better judgments and we can
研讨场景。然后是乐观，我倾向于在基于认知行为疗法（CBT）的基础上做更多的事情。所以让我们挑战我们所拥有的那些消极想法，无论是10个人一直给我发邮件寻求帮助，我感到沮丧的情况。我们能否将其重构为一种更有帮助和更健康的想法，即：当人们需要支持时，我是首选的人，那四个小东西真的可以促成更积极的日常工作、自我意识，这就是英雄模型，简而言之。
workshop scenarios. And then optimism, I tend to do that a bit more on the kind of CBT based of things. So let's challenge some of those negative thoughts that we have, whether it's a case of 10 people keep emailing me for help and I'm getting frustrated. Can we reframe that something that's a more helpful and healthy thought of, I'm the go-to person when people need support and those little four things can really contribute to a much more kind of positive day-to-day working, sense of self and that's the hero model in a bit
我喜欢它，非常感谢。我也喜欢这个播客，能够以这种方式引导人们了解这一点真是太不可思议了。我想当你说话的时候，我在思考乐观，我在思考当我们处于教育系统中时，我们习惯于思考我们的能力水平是多少。有时我们发现自己处于这样一种境地，实际上我们觉得我们没有达到我们通常期望自己的水平。我知道这是我们在录音前谈论过的事情，那是我可能在A-level和本科阶段都经历过的事情。我希望我当时知道实际上寻求帮助是可以的，实际上如果你
of a nutshell. I love it, thank you so much. I love this podcast as well, how incredible to be able to kind of talk people through this. And I guess as you were talking, I was thinking about the optimism and I was thinking about when we're kind of in an education system, we kind of get used to thinking about what our level of capability is. And sometimes we find ourselves in situations where actually we feel like we're falling short of where we would usually expect ourselves to be. And I know this is something we spoke about before we hit record, that that's something I experienced probably both in A levels and in my undergrad as well. And I wish I'd known that actually it's okay to ask for help and actually if
觉得你没有发挥出你的全部潜力，你通常看待自己的方式，或者你认为自己有能力做到的事情，请务必去学术写作中心。请务必联系你的导师。请务必联系并询问关于你如何达到你被评判的标准更具体的指导。杰克，你会怎么说？100%，这是我意识到的事情。我希望我能早点意识到。我通过开放大学完成了两个本科学位，现在正在伯克贝克学院攻读硕士学位。我在伯克贝克的方法非常不同，因为我正在寻求帮助并
you feel like you're not living up to your full potential, where you typically see yourself or what you see yourself as being capable of, please do get yourself to the Centre for Academic Writing. Please do reach out to your tutor. Please do reach out and ask for more specific guidance about how you can meet the criteria that you are being judged against. What would you say about that Jack? 100% it's something I've realized. I wish I'd realized it sooner. I've done two undergrads with the Open University and I'm now doing my masters at Birkbeck. My approach at Birkbeck has been very different in terms of I am reaching out for help and
充分利用机会，无论他们是否围绕评估进行问答。我现在的心态是，这不会伤害我，只会可能帮助我。所以，以前当我年轻一点或者在开放大学做的时候，我想，没关系，我有简报。而现在，正如乔·格雷（Joe Gray）所说，我在我的方法上是主动的，我是那个发起寻求帮助的人，因为导师和学院通常不会主动联系。如果我想要那种支持，就得由我来说出来。
making the most out of opportunities, whether they do Q&A's around the assessments. My mind frame now is going to this is not going to hurt me, it is only going to possibly help. So, whereas before when I was a little bit younger or doing it with the Open University, I think it's okay I've got the brief. Whereas now I'm, as Joe Gray would say, I'm proactive in my approach, I'm the one instigating help because tutors and colleges typically won't reach out. It's up to me to speak up if I want that support.
这也是我在工作中鼓励的事情，因为我和很多人一起工作，都是有抱负的心理学家，一年级的学生。我会说任何你想讨论的事情，随时给我发邮件，我非常乐意提供帮助、指引、推荐、播客，无论它是什么。我有我多年的知识和经验，我想分享，而且在学院、学校、大学里，有人热衷于帮助学生。你只需要说，嗨，我是需要帮助的学生之一，他们总是会很乐意。请继续说下去，请继续消除这个过程的污名化，因为实际上我需要不止一次地听到这个，我可能只在18岁刚开始学位时听到过一次，实际上我当时18、19和20岁。我是一个年轻人，所以我没有满21岁
And it's something I encourage as well in work because I work with a lot of people, all aspiring psychologists, people in first year students. I'll say anything you want to discuss, feel free to send me an email, I'm more than happy to help, signpost, recommend, podcast, you know, whatever it may be. I've got my years of knowledge and experience that I want to share and there are people, you know, in colleges, in schools, in universities, who are passionate about helping students. You just need to say, hi, I'm one of the students that need help and they'll always be happy to. Please keep saying that and please keep Please keep saying that and please keep deshaming that process because actually I needed to hear that more than once and I probably only heard that maybe once at the start of my degree when I was 18 and actually I was 18, 19 and 20. I was a young one so I didn't turn 21
直到我几乎已经完成了，基本上是因为我是六月出生的。我从来没有，我会说，坐在讲座的第一排。那往往是成熟的学生，那些21岁及以上的人，但那些成熟的学生以不同的方式获取和互动他们的教育。我总是会想，如果我能像他们那样应用自己，我会做得更好。而且没有，你知道，我想我几乎偏离了我的根源。因为当我在七年级、八年级和九年级时，我热爱学习。我喜欢它。我做了所有的家庭作业。我做了所有的阅读。我对此非常有动力。我想我的失败是男孩，杰克。
until I'd almost finished already basically because I'm a June baby. And I never once, I would say, sat on the front row of a lecture. It did tend to be the mature students, those that were 21 and above, but those mature students accessed and interacted with their education in a different way. And I always would have been like, if I'd been able to apply myself in the way that they had, I would have done much better. And there's no, you know, I think I almost got away from my roots actually. Because when I was in year seven, year eight and nine, I loved learning. I loved it. I did all the homework. I did all the reading. I was very motivated by that. I think my downfall was boys, Jack.
是的，向合唱团布道。我做了所有的阅读。我对此非常有动力。我想我的失败是男孩，杰克。是的，向合唱团布道。十年级时，我想，哦，那边有一些男孩。我就做得少了。但我希望我知道。学习很酷。你可以是，我不知道，书呆子，聪明的人，这很安全。你可以做两件事。你可以和男孩亲热，同时还在学习，还在取得成就，这没关系。如果我把这一点带到我的学位中，就像你可以拥有这种非常充满活力的生活，但同时你仍然可以尽可能努力地工作并取得成就，并且绝对可以寻求帮助，你知道。是的，你可以茁壮成长，你可以变得聪明并取得成就是安全的。是的，不，100%，100%。
Yeah. Preach into the reading. I was very motivated by that. I think my downfall was boys, Jack. Yeah. Preacher to the choir. Year 10, I was like, oh, there's some boys over there. And I just did less. But I wish I'd known. It's cool to learn. It's safe for you to be, I don't know, the bod, the clever one. And you can do both things. You can be snogging boys and still learning and still achieving and that's okay. And had I carried that through to my degree, it's like it's okay for you to have this really vibrant life but also for you to still work as hard as you can and to achieve and definitely to ask for help, you know. Yeah, it's safe for you to thrive and for you to be clever and achieve. Yeah, no, 100%, 100%.
这绝对是我作为成熟学生回去后学到的东西。我经历过几次传统上会被视为失败的事情，因为我不得不从大学退学。我想我实际上读了三次高中。然后大学，我想我开始了两次。然后我通过开放大学以成熟学生的身份回归，成功完成了学业。我做了两次，现在正在攻读硕士学位。
That's definitely something I've learned as a mature student going back. I've had several kind of what traditionally would be seen as failings in terms of I've had to drop out of college. I think I actually did sixth form three times. Then university, I think I did two full starts. And then I kind of cracked it with the open university returning as a mature student. I did that twice and now into a master.
所以绝对必须有一种感觉，你知道，你必须投入工作和努力。这是我，说出来听起来很陈词滥调，但我绝对注意到当我投入努力和时间到我的学习中时，它得到了回报，我的成绩很棒，我想，哦，我实际上只需要埋头苦干，请一天假，然后去做就行了，但有时也必须是正确的时间，所以我知道我绝对尝试过在大学做事情，但我当时的心态不对，我没有正确的支持，我这样做是因为我想做，但那对我来说不是正确的情况
So there's definitely got to be a sense of, you know, you've got to put in the work and the effort. And that's something I've, it sounds cliche to say it, but I've definitely noticed when I've put in the effort and the time into my studies it's paid off and my grades have been great and I think oh I actually just need to buckle down and book that day off work and just do it but there's also a case of sometimes it's got to be the right time so I know I've definitely tried to do stuff with university and college where I wasn't in the right headspace, I didn't have the right support and I was doing it because I wanted to do it but it wasn't the right case for me
退后一步，然后回到那个状态，我可以看到实际上有时一切都必须协调一致，当我真正有动力和能力去学习和充分参与时，因为我不想只是，你知道，用一半的努力去做，特别是当我们考虑学生贷款之类的事情时，或者如果你是自费的，你知道，你不想浪费那笔钱，那个机会，因为有关于你可以和不可以获得多少资金的规定，去做并全力以赴。那实际上是我接下来的问题，那个，你知道，我想感谢你使这一点正常化，实际上，有时它第一次不起作用，有时它第二次
and stepping back and then returning to that I can see actually sometimes it's got everything's got to aligned when I've got the motivation and the capacity to actually learn and engage fully because I don't want to just do it you know with half effort especially when we think around things like student loans or if you're self-funding you know you don't want to waste that money that opportunity because there are you know regulations on how much funding you can and can't get do it and give it everything. That was going to be my next question actually that, that, you know, I want to thank you for normalizing that actually, sometimes it doesn't work the first time, sometimes it doesn't
不起作用。但实际上，如果你仍然感到不满足，或者如果你觉得实际上，这有不同的角度，或者你现在更有能力应用自己，或者对自己负责，或者你的生活因素更稳定了，回去是可以的，别人怎么说并不重要。我相信当你第三次说你要去大学时，肯定有人可能对此有意见。但这并不意味着他们比你的意见和你的能力更重要
work the second time. But actually, if you still feel unfulfilled, or if you feel like actually, there's a different angle to this, or that you are now more able to apply yourself, or to hold yourself accountable, or that your life factors are more stabilized, it's okay to go back, it doesn't matter what other people are saying. I'm sure when you said you were going to apply yourself or to hold yourself accountable or that your life factors are more stabilised, it's okay to go back. It doesn't matter what other people are saying. I'm sure when you said you were going to uni for the third time, there were people who probably had opinions about that. But it doesn't mean they're more important than your opinion and your ability
以及你自我实现的需要。我可以问一下，当涉及到，我做了学生贷款，我知道有时你可以提取的本科和研究生贷款的年限是有上限的，你可能比我更了解这一点。杰克，如果可以的话，你能为我们介绍一下吗？是的，绝对可以。所以同样，我会把这个归结为运气。所以我通过开放大学完成了我的第一个本科学位。我学习了语言研究。我有两个爱好。从十几岁中期开始我就有了。我一直对语言、文化和心理学充满热情，所以非常以人为本。所以在法国大学尝试失败后
and your need to self-actualise. Can I ask when it comes to kind of, I did student finance, I know that sometimes you have a maximum number of kind of years of undergrad and post-grad finance you can draw on, you might know more about that than me. Could you talk us through that a little bit, Jack, if you can? Yeah, absolutely. So again, I will put this one down to luck. So I did my first undergrad with the Open University. I did language studies. I had two passions. I've had them since mid-teenage years. I've always been passionate about languages and cultures and psychology, so very people-focused. And so after a failed attempt
，我打算在法国学习心理学以满足两个需求，但计划非常糟糕，我只是带着一个手提箱到达了大学。那里几乎没有支持。我实际上无家可归。我住在法国南部的一些酒店和汽车旅馆里，我想，不，这不是我希望的。我需要回家。所以我去了利物浦霍普大学（Liverpool Hope）。同样，这是一个最后一分钟的决定，那不适合我。我的心态不对。我想我当时在心理健康方面有点挣扎，
at university in France, I was going to do psychology in France to save both needs, but it was very poorly planned and I just arrived at the university with a suitcase. There was minimal support there. I was technically homeless. I was staying in some hotels and motels in the south of France and I thought, no, this isn't what I hope. I need to come home. So I went to Liverpool Hope. Again, it was a last minute decision and that wasn't the fit for me. I wasn't in the head space. I think I was struggling a little with my mental health,
我的性取向。所以我只是回家了，工作了几年。我想大约三四年后，我正在工作，我在做酒吧工作，那是凌晨四点，你知道，洗着浸透啤酒的吧台垫和布等等。我想我想要一些不同的东西。我需要回到教育中。学生贷款有延迟，所以我推迟了一年，然后我实际上获得了资助，因为这是我的
my sexual orientation. So I just came home, worked for a couple of years. And I think about three, four years later, I was working, I was doing bar work and it was four in the morning, you know, washing bare-soaked bare mats and cloths and everything. I think I want something different. I need to get back into education. There was a delay with the student loan so I deferred it for a year and then I actually got funding because it was my
第一笔学费贷款。所以我被告知你可以一直这样做，直到你完成学位。所以开放大学有非常灵活的时间表。所以无论我是在三年内还是在12年内完成它，它都会得到资助，因为这是一个学位，那是允许的部分。最后我得到了三等学位，我对此并不满意。我绝对认为我可以做得更好，但同样，我认为那是成熟度的问题，只是在学习中走过场。所以我又想研究心理学，我真正充满热情的东西，当时我想现在仍然是这样，如果你学习STEM（科学、技术、工程、数学）
first tuition fee loan. So I was informed you can do it until you complete the degree. So with the Open University they have very flexible schedules. So whether I did it over three years or up to 12 it'll be funded because it's the one degree and that was the kind of allowing part. I got a third in the end of that which I wasn't happy with. I definitely think I could do better but again I think it was that case of maturity and just kind of going through the motions with the studying. So I wanted to kind of look into psychology again what I was really passionate about and at the time I think it's still the case you can get funding for a second undergrad if it's a STEM
学科，你可以获得第二个本科学位的资助。所以因为心理学是一门科学，它是适用的。所以我实际上很幸运获得了第二个本科学位的资助，在那里我投入了更多的时间和精力。我的本科成绩从三等提高到了二等一，这对我来说是一个了不起的成就。这绝对更多地反映了
subject. So because psychology is a science, it was applicable. So I was actually lucky to get funding for a second undergrad where I invested a lot more time and effort. And I went up from a third to a two one in my undergrad, which was an amazing achievement for me. It was definitely more of a reflection
我相信我有能力做到的事情。它仍然满足了那些需求。所以我在这方面很幸运。但是，是的，所以无论学位是什么，你都会获得资助直到完成。如果你想做第二个STEM学位，还有额外的资助。我很幸运我按照语言然后科学的顺序完成了。好的，太棒了。而且我了解到实际上《有抱负的心理学家》播客
of what I believed I was capable about. And it still fulfilled those needs. So I'm quite lucky in that respect. And but, yeah, so you're funded for whatever the degree is in completion. And there's also additional funding if you want to do a second one of STEM. So I'm lucky I did that order of languages and then of science. OK, amazing. And I understand that actually the Aspiring Psychologist podcast
可能在给你最后的推动力去攻读你确定的硕士学位方面发挥了作用，这是正确的吗？100%。我不尴尬承认这一点。那是两三次活动，所以我知道我实际上在2023年的英国心理学会（BPS）职业节上看到你演讲。我想你是主旨演讲人，我想，嗯，需要做一些心理学方面的工作，你知道，听到一些这种多样化的工作模式是很好的。当时，我想我要么在电话销售要么在客户服务，所以同样我很难进入这个空间。我正在做我的工作塑造和心理健康急救，在
might have been instrumental in giving you a final shove towards your identified masters, is that correct? 100%. I'm not embarrassed to admit it. It was two or three events, so I know I actually went to see you speak at the BPS Career Festival I think in 2023. I think you were the keynote speaker and I thought, well, need to work something psychological, you know, it's good to hear some of these kind of diverse working patterns. At the time, I think I was either in tele-sales or customer service, so again I was struggling to get into this space. I was doing my job crafting and my mental health first aid and at
那时我正在考虑走那种培训心理健康从业者（PWP）的路线，我将要面对人并以那种方式提供支持，然后我听了你和乔·格雷（Joe Gray）做的播客，我们前几天在LinkedIn上还在开玩笑，因为她实际上是我的导师之一，在攻读硕士学位时，我没有意识到那是同一个乔·格雷，但她解释了组织心理学，这对我职业生涯所处的位置听起来非常迷人。老实说，我相当喜欢企业生活方式。我喜欢朝九晚五，我喜欢家庭办公室，我知道在心理健康工作中情况并非总是如此。所以这是一个什么适合我的问题
that time I was thinking of going down the kind of trainee PWP route and I was going to be you know person facing and do support that way and then I listened to the podcast you did with Joe Gray who we were joking about actually on LinkedIn the other day because she was actually one of my tutors and doing my masters I didn't realize it was the same Joe Gray, but she was explained around organisational psychology and that sounded so fascinating to me for where I am in my career. I'll be honest, I quite like the corporate lifestyle. I like a nine to five, I like a home office, which I know in mental health work's not always the case. And so it was a case of what's the right fit for me
因为我喜欢帮助别人。这就是我作为我是谁的使命宣言。我想帮助别人。同样，我必须发挥创造力，在我想做的事情之间，即我的天生使命、我的召唤，以及我，我也想要一份稳定的工作，我也想要稳定的收入，我想要一些为了我自己的幸福，然后我在这个播客上听到了组织心理学，我想是的，那是事实，这就是我要做的，然后我找到了伯克贝克学院的硕士学位，加上论文是一年到18个月。我想它适合我的生活方式。我可以作为硕士学位获得资助。所以我只是去做了，我必须承认这很棒。所以谢谢你的播客节目。哦，谢谢。你知道，我在某天做茶时在厨房里想出的那个小宝贝，实际上正在帮助塑造人们现在的职业选择，也是未来的职业选择。
because I love helping people. And that's my kind of mission statement for who I am. I want to help people. And again, I had to get creative with how I was going to do that between what I want to do is my kind of innate mission, my calling between my, I also want a stable job, I also want a stable income, I want something after my
我没有忘记这一点，这是一种真正的特权。但它也，你知道，我没有从这个播客中赚钱。我每个月花500英镑我自己的钱来把它放在一起，这甚至还没有拿工资。我不为我的时间收费。所以人们在每周的时间表中建立时间来观看它、收听它，并真正从中汲取学习点来改变他们的生活、改变他们家人的生活，以及可能改变他们未来将与之共事的人的生活，你知道，这很可爱。所以我很高兴它产生了涟漪，因为我向人们推荐了这个播客。它甚至塑造了我的看法，我在现在支持人们时的经验。我可以
own well-being and then I heard about organizational psychology on this podcast and I thought yeah that's the sad fact, that's what I'm going to do and then I found the Masters with Birkbeck, it's one year to 18 months with the dissertation. I thought it fits my lifestyle. I could get funding for it as a Masters. So I just went for it and it's been great I must admit. So thank you for the podcast episode. Oh thank you. You know the idea that I'm my little baby that I came up with in my kitchen one day when I was cooking tea is actually helping shape people's career options both now but also in the future.
我自己的幸福感，然后我在这个播客上听到了组织心理学，我想，是的，这就是悲哀的事实，这就是我要做的事情，然后我发现了伯克贝克学院的硕士课程，包括论文在内需要一年到18个月。我觉得它很适合我的生活方式。我可以作为硕士生获得资助。所以我决定尝试一下，我必须承认这很棒。所以谢谢你的播客节目。哦，谢谢你。你知道，我在厨房做饭时想出的这个小点子，实际上正在帮助塑造人们现在以及未来的职业选择，这种想法让我感到很欣慰。
It's not lost on me, it's a real privilege. But also it kind of, you know, I don't earn money from this podcast. It cost me 500 pounds a month of my own money to put it together and that's without even taking a wage for it. I don't charge for my time. So the fact that people are building time into their weekly schedules to watch it, to listen to it and to actually take the learning points from it to change their lives, change their family's lives and potentially the lives of the people they will work with in future, you know, it's lovely. So I'm really pleased that it ripples because I've recommended the podcast to people. It's even shaped my perceptions, my experiences when I'm now supporting people. I can
我并没有忘记这一点，这真是一种荣幸。但同时，你知道，我并没有从这个播客中赚钱。我每个月自掏腰包500英镑来制作它，这还不包括我自己的工资。我不收取任何时间费用。所以，人们愿意在每周的时间表中抽出时间来观看、收听，并真正从中汲取学习要点来改变他们的生活、改变他们家人的生活，以及未来可能改变他们共事者的生活，这真的很棒。所以我很高兴它能产生涟漪效应，因为我已经向人们推荐了这个播客。它甚至塑造了我的观念和经验，现在当我支持别人时，我可以
think of at least five people in my role who I'm kind of unofficially supporting or coaching just whatever they need who are you know aspiring psychologists in one capacity or another and again that's helped shape you know my perspective to support others as well so it definitely ripples out. One of my favourite things is when people request access to the aspiring psychologist community which is my free Facebook group there's a little kind of Q&A there how did you hear about the When people request access to the Aspiring Psychologist community, which is my free Facebook group, there's a little kind of Q&A there, how did you hear about the group or how did you hear about the podcast? I love it when people say, actually, my university lecturer
想想看，在我的角色中，至少有五个人是我在非正式地支持或指导的，无论他们需要什么。他们都是以某种身份渴望成为心理学家的人。同样，这也帮助塑造了我支持他人的视角，所以这绝对会产生连锁反应。我最喜欢的事情之一就是当人们申请加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist community）时，这是我的免费Facebook群组。那里有一个小问答，问你是怎么听说这个群组或播客的。我喜欢人们说：“其实是我的大学讲师告诉我的。”
told me about it. I'm like, oh, that is so nice. That must feel amazing. That is so nice. Because it's getting quite leggy now, really. It will be four years in December, I think I'm right in saying. That's not a new podcast. I am currently in preparation for planning the 200th episode and what that might look like. And that's been 200 weeks of my life Jack because because of the way I work I need to either be on or off. So with the podcast I am on every week, every week for you know what are we now 187, 188 something like that. Every week there's been a podcast episode and all of the backoffish
我当时就想，哦，那太好了。那感觉一定很棒。那真的太好了。因为现在这个播客已经做了很久了。我想我没记错的话，到十二月就满四年了。这可不是一个新播客。我目前正在筹划第200期节目，思考它会是什么样子。杰克，这200周是我生命的一部分，因为我的工作方式，我必须要么全情投入，要么完全抽离。所以对于播客，我每周都在坚持，每周都在做，我们现在已经做到第187、188期左右了。每周都有播客节目，以及所有背后的
shenanigans that go with that each of the episodes has about 200 steps involved like and for me like that's just one of my regular go-to's I work with my accountability coach Ben to just make sure that I'm you know covering all these Anyone time I've got kind of maybe five six seven different episodes at various different stages of production. Like it's a military operation. But actually, the fact that it's making a difference and becoming, becoming like a regular, you know, a stalwart in psychology is amazing. So thank you to you, Jack. And thank you to, to my listeners and watchers as well. What a treat. I think that's a good assessment, something I know I did in my undergrad as I'm sure many people listening today will have that kind of panic over grades,
琐事。每一期节目大约涉及200个步骤。对我来说，这只是我的日常工作之一。我和我的责任教练本（Ben）合作，确保我涵盖了所有这些。任何时候我可能都有五、六、七个不同阶段的节目在制作中。这就像一场军事行动。但事实上，它正在产生影响，并成为心理学领域的一个常态和中坚力量，这太棒了。所以谢谢你，杰克。也谢谢我的听众和观众。真是太棒了。我认为这是一个很好的评估，我相信今天收听的许多人也会像我在本科时那样，对成绩、作业、等级感到恐慌，
assignments, classification. I really had to do a bit of reflection and think what is it I want to do. Similar to what companies will have, I gave myself a little mission statement, which I kind of just alluded to, of I wanted to help people. In my head, or especially in year one or year two of my undergrad,
我真的必须进行一些反思，思考我到底想做什么。和公司一样，我给自己设定了一个小小的使命宣言，也就是我刚才提到的，我想帮助别人。在我的脑海里，特别是在我本科一年级或二年级的时候，
in my head that was simply, I want to help people, I've got to be a clinical psychologist, I've got to do steps A, B, and C. And that was at a very limited lens. And as I was panicking about grades I was trying to come up with a plan B and I thought well actually if I want to help people there are many different ways I can help people it doesn't have to be solely as a psychologist and then
在我的脑海里，那很简单，就是“我想帮助别人，我必须成为一名临床心理学家，我必须完成A、B、C步骤”。那时的眼光非常局限。当我为成绩感到恐慌时，我试图想出一个B计划，我想，其实如果我想帮助别人，有很多不同的方式，不一定非要作为一名心理学家，然后
that's when I've tried to diversify what I do so even my now, so my job title's regional support officer. So I work as a regional manager, supporting services and teams. So on paper, you know, it's not very psychological, it's not very supportive. And it's something I kind of bring to the role. So I do have staff members ringing me in times of crisis, or if they need emotional support, I've delivered interventions to the people we support as well. I've put things in place around training and inductions, again, to support people. So I'm still fulfilling my mission statement of wanting to help in a slightly untraditional way.
这就是我尝试多元化发展的原因。所以即使是现在，我的职位名称是区域支持官。我担任区域经理，支持服务和团队。从纸面上看，这看起来不太像心理学，也不太像支持性工作。但这确实是我带入这个角色的东西。所以确实有员工在危机时刻打电话给我，或者如果他们需要情感支持，我也为我们支持的人提供过干预。我在培训和入职方面也落实了一些措施，同样是为了支持人们。所以我仍然以一种稍微非传统的方式履行着我想帮助他人的使命宣言。
But even yourself, like you say, with the podcast, that's not a traditional duty one would expect of a clinical psychologist, but there are ways that you can help people in an untraditional sense, you know, your community, your listeners, people getting that support they need from a relevant source. It's accessible, it's not behind you know a paywall if you've got Spotify or you know AppMusic and any good podcast platform, they can access guidance from leading professionals, which again is a creative way in job crafting really.
但就像你说的，即使是你自己，做播客也不是临床心理学家的传统职责，但你可以以非传统的方式帮助人们，比如你的社区、你的听众，人们从相关的来源获得他们需要的支持。它是可获取的，如果你有Spotify、Apple Music或任何好的播客平台，它就不在付费墙之后，他们可以从领先的专业人士那里获得指导，这确实是一种创造性的工作塑造方式。
Absolutely. And I will tell you off camera what the plans are for the 200 episode series, but it's very excited. So yeah, watch this space, listeners and viewers, and I will tell you more as soon as I can. Jack, is there anything we haven't covered that you think would be really useful for us to do before we finish together today? I think one of the things I would like to say to anyone listening and watching today
绝对是这样。我会在节目结束后告诉你关于200期系列节目的计划，但我非常兴奋。所以，敬请期待，听众和观众们，我一有机会就会告诉你们更多。杰克，在我们今天结束之前，你觉得还有什么我们没涵盖到但对大家非常有用的吗？我想对今天收听和观看的每一个人说的一件事是，
is don't be afraid to get creative with your experience and your journey. It's taken me many years to kind of end up where I am. And that was just making the most out of opportunities. And some of the kind of positions that I know a lot of students more cover for around the trainee PWPs, APs, DECLINs are very competitive. So not to get, you know, disheartened with that.
不要害怕在你的经历和旅程中发挥创造力。我花了很多年才走到今天这一步。这只是充分利用了机会。我知道很多学生关注的职位，比如实习心理健康从业者（PWP）、助理心理学家（AP）、临床心理学博士（DClin），竞争非常激烈。所以不要因此而灰心丧气。
Make the most out of what you do have, whether it's, you know, aened with that make the most out of what you do have whether it's you know a psychology related role or not my role is not psychology related whatsoever on paper but it's my approach I approach things with evidence-based I approach things with theory and so I definitely want to encourage people with that engage in that kind of job crafting behaviors try and find something that fulfills your needs and the needs of your employer and there will be ways that you can kind of do the two you know together and really reflect on what it is you want to do, what you want to achieve and just going back on
充分利用你所拥有的，无论它是否与心理学相关。我的角色在纸面上完全与心理学无关，但这是我的方法。我用循证的方法处理事情，我用理论处理事情，所以我绝对想鼓励人们这样做。参与那种工作塑造行为，尝试找到能满足你需求和雇主需求的事情，你会有办法将两者结合起来。真正反思你想做什么，你想实现什么，回顾一下
the experiences as well. Think of the ways you can market them to employers when you are going for declines or the AP roles. I often find because I've conducted a lot of interviews in this current role, sometimes you need to be quite clear with how your marketing skills, similar to how we would write essays, you know, once you've made a point, relate it back to the question, relate it to how that's going to benefit your employer. If it's, you know, a time you overcome something, tell them, that means I can keep cool, calm and collected in a, you know, a situation. Let people really know what those skills are because they are all transferable.
这些经历。当你申请临床心理学博士或助理心理学家职位时，思考如何向雇主推销这些经历。我经常发现，因为我在当前职位上进行过很多面试，有时你需要非常清楚地说明你的营销技巧，就像我们写论文一样，一旦你提出了一个观点，就把它与问题联系起来，联系到它将如何使你的雇主受益。如果这是一个你克服困难的时刻，告诉他们，这意味着我可以在某种情况下保持冷静、沉着。让人们真正了解这些技能是什么，因为它们都是可迁移的。
As cliche as it sounds, sometimes you need to connect the dots for whoever you're interviewing rather than make your own interpretation. Yeah amazing and I think I would really encourage people to not think about a timeline you know so absolutely if you've done your psychology undergrad and you know you're like oh I'm 21 now I need to be an assistant psychologist by the time I'm 22 I would say that's probably unrealistic. That's probably putting more pressure on yourself than you need because actually people who
虽然听起来很陈词滥调，但有时你需要为面试你的人连接这些点，而不是让他们自己去解读。是的，太棒了。我真的会鼓励人们不要去想时间表。如果你完成了心理学本科，然后想“哦，我现在21岁，我需要在22岁之前成为一名助理心理学家”，我会说这可能是不现实的。这可能是在给自己施加不必要的压力，因为实际上那些
are often getting shortlisted for AP interviews have maybe done a few years of relevant experience roles. They may already have done a masters. And so so yeah, take that pressure off and don't assume just because you've got a psych undergrad that you can go on straight into an AP role because it's not impossible, but it's very uncommon, even when I was graduating. And yes, do still apply for the jobs because you might get lucky, but please know, speaking from someone who is quite seasoned in this now, you really will be a better assistant if that's the route you're wanting to go down for having done those relevant experience roles.
经常入围助理心理学家面试的人，可能已经有了几年的相关工作经验。他们可能已经完成了硕士学位。所以，是的，卸下那个压力，不要仅仅因为你有一个心理学本科学位就认为你可以直接进入助理心理学家的角色，因为这并非不可能，但非常罕见，即使在我毕业时也是如此。是的，还是要申请这些工作，因为你可能会幸运地被录取，但请知道，作为一个现在经验丰富的人，如果你走这条路，拥有那些相关的工作经验会让你成为一名更好的助理。
So by the time I was an AP, I had worked as a student support assistant at university. I had worked as a home carer. I had worked in a call centre as we've already covered today. I then went and worked for Milton Keynes Council for two and a half years in a rehab assistant role for physically disabled adults living in the community. I then did some honorary AP work using my annual leave for 10 days across a couple of months I did that. And then I got a paid AP role. So that is not straight out of university. I also went travelling around the world for six months and saved up to do that beforehand.
所以当我成为助理心理学家时，我曾在大学担任过学生支持助理。我做过家庭护理员。我曾在呼叫中心工作过，正如我们今天已经提到的。然后我为米尔顿凯恩斯议会工作了两年半，担任身体残疾成年人的康复助理。我利用年假做了10天的荣誉助理心理学家工作，持续了几个月。然后我得到了一份有薪水的助理心理学家工作。所以这并不是直接从大学毕业就得到的。在此之前，我还去环游世界了六个月，并为此存了钱。
So yeah, really do take the timeline off this, I would say. Yeah, 100%. My timeline has not been cohesive to follow. And I was trying to map it out mentally for this journey. I thought, I forgot I did this small stint in the south of France back in 2013. What was I thinking? Definitely make just enjoy the journey, not the destination as cliché as it is and enjoy the experience and just think of it as experience gaining diverse experience That's something I like as an employee when I'm doing interviews with people for support roles is what can they bring to the team? What is suitable for us? What experience have they got working with people. And whether it's, you know, people with mental health issues, drug and alcohol and substance learning difficulties, it's still a supportive role helping people.
所以，是的，我真的建议把时间表从这件事上拿掉。是的，百分之百。我的时间表并不连贯。我试图在脑海中为这段旅程绘制蓝图。我想到，我忘了我2013年在法国南部还有过一段小插曲。我在想什么呢？一定要享受旅程，而不是终点，尽管这很陈词滥调。享受经历，把它看作是获得多样化经验的过程。这是我作为雇主在面试支持岗位时喜欢的东西：他们能为团队带来什么？什么适合我们？他们在与人打交道方面有什么经验？无论是心理健康问题、毒品和酒精、物质滥用还是学习困难，这仍然是一个帮助人们的支持性角色。
It's just might not be the way as a student, you've planned it as a perfect linear fashion, but it is all relevant. Just enjoy that process, Make those connections as well. You know, your own kind of career network as well. And slowly it does kind of get there to where you want. And get your reflective journal out, you know? Write about this stuff. Really think about shaping, growing,
这可能不是你作为学生所规划的那种完美的线性方式，但这一切都是相关的。享受这个过程，建立那些联系。你自己的职业网络也是如此。慢慢地，它确实会到达你想要的地方。拿出你的反思日记，写下这些东西。真正思考塑造、成长，
looking at your vulnerabilities, looking at your strengths, really honestly start writing, you know do it either on your phone or an actual book or on your computer, start it, do it, keep it up. 100% in both the corporate world and now where I am working kind of third sector there is a lot around reflection. It's something we encourage with our practitioners and recovery workers, you know, to be aware of their own shortcomings, whether it's more professional weaknesses around systems and case notes,
审视你的脆弱，审视你的优势，真正诚实地开始写作。无论是在手机上、笔记本上还是电脑上，开始写，坚持下去。百分之百，无论是在企业界还是我现在工作的第三部门，都有很多关于反思的内容。我们鼓励我们的从业者和康复工作者意识到自己的不足，无论是关于系统和病例记录的专业弱点，
or whether it's something in the therapeutic work they do. It's something you've got to be mindful of if you are thinking of working in mental health and counseling, even if you're thinking more of in mental health and counselling. Even if you're thinking more of a corporate world as well, so what I do in organisational psychology, again, we have to do a lot of reflection for our biases when it comes to recruitment, selection, job design.
还是他们在治疗工作中遇到的问题。如果你考虑在心理健康和咨询领域工作，即使你考虑的是企业界，你也必须注意这一点。我在组织心理学中所做的工作，同样，我们在招聘、选拔、工作设计方面必须对我们的偏见进行大量的反思。
So there is always reflection when you're working with people and the interpretation of people. So that's definitely a skill you can't develop enough. That's again come with age but I would definitely recommend it for anyone listening and watching today. Yeah amazing. Thank you so much for your time in speaking to us today Jack. Please do keep us updated on your career path as it unfolds as well and yeah thank you again for pitching this episode. path as it unfolds as well. And yeah, thank you again for pitching this episode. I think it's going to be such a useful shot in the arm to so many people, but also just, you know, letting people know it's okay that and that's something I'm proud of now that I have failed. I have failed several times and it's not going to plan but I've made the most out of
所以当你与人打交道和解读他人时，总会有反思。这绝对是一项你永远无法充分发展的技能。这确实随着年龄的增长而增长，但我绝对会向今天收听和观看的任何人推荐它。是的，太棒了。非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈，杰克。请务必让我们随时了解你的职业道路的发展。再次感谢你提出这一期节目。我想这对很多人来说将是一剂非常有用的强心针，同时也让人们知道，失败是可以的。我现在很自豪，因为我失败过。我失败过好几次，事情并没有按计划进行，但我充分利用了
that and now I'm at the start of this really good kind of career trajectory. I'm towards the end of my masters now, I'm just doing my dissertation. The journey will never stop, there's always something you can learn, there's always ways you can develop. So don't worry if the grades are never quite what you expected or the jobs aren't quite what you expected. They all form this bigger puzzle that is you and that will definitely form your career later down the line as well. Amazing and I think I also did an episode on all the ways I failed in psychology or the seven ways I've failed in psychology or something like that.
这一点，现在我正处于一个非常好的职业轨迹的起点。我现在快要完成硕士学位了，正在写论文。旅程永远不会停止，总有你可以学习的东西，总有你可以发展的方式。所以不要担心成绩是否不如预期，或者工作是否不如预期。它们都构成了你这个更大的拼图，这肯定也会在未来塑造你的职业生涯。太棒了，我想我也做过一期关于我在心理学中所有失败方式的节目，或者说我在心理学中失败的七种方式之类的。
So what I'll do is I'll try and remember to mark that as the next episode on YouTube. But if you enjoy this chat about failure and you want to be validated in your own failure, do take a look out for that episode. Thank you so much for your time, Jack, and enjoy the beautiful blackpool sunshine, won't you? Absolutely, absolutely. Thank you again for having me today. Thank you. Thank you so much for my guest today. Please do drop some support, some encouragement into the comments if you're watching this on YouTube. Please do like and share this episode and if you're not already subscribing to the channel please do so. Subscribing to channels and following podcast shows of any creator that you
所以我会尽量记得在YouTube上把那一期标记为下一期。但如果你喜欢这次关于失败的谈话，并且想在自己的失败中获得认可，请务必关注那一期节目。非常感谢你的时间，杰克，享受美丽的布莱克浦阳光吧，好吗？当然，当然。再次感谢你今天邀请我。谢谢。非常感谢我今天的嘉宾。如果你在YouTube上观看，请在评论区留下一些支持和鼓励。请点赞并分享这一期节目，如果你还没有订阅频道，请订阅。订阅频道并关注任何你
rate really is the kindest thing you can do for anybody for free. If you haven't already read the books The Clinical Psychologist Collective and The Aspiring Psychologist Collective, why not? Now's your time. Please do dive into the links on the description or in the show notes to grab your copy. If you've already read one or both of them please do take a moment to rate and review them on Amazon or Goodreads. It would be so gratefully appreciated and helps other people browsing the site to be shown this content which is so useful for their career and development. If you are ready to develop yourself
欣赏的创作者的播客节目，真的是你能为任何人做的最友善的免费事情。如果你还没有读过《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这两本书，为什么不读呢？现在是时候了。请点击描述或节目说明中的链接来获取你的副本。如果你已经读过其中一本或两本，请花点时间在亚马逊或Goodreads上给它们评分和评论。我们将不胜感激，这也有助于其他浏览网站的人看到这些对他们的职业和发展非常有用的内容。如果你准备好发展自己，
and thinking about this being your time, you're ready for the next step, or that you just don't have the people around you to help you become the clinician that you believe you can be and would like to be, then please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join for just 30 pounds a month
并认为现在是你的时间，你准备好迈出下一步，或者你身边没有可以帮助你成为你认为自己能成为且想成为的临床医生的人，那么请务必查看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），你每月只需30英镑即可加入，
with no minimum term. And if you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And if you're ready for something a little bit more high touch, there's the Ready to Rise program which you can join with me for an entire year where you get 12 one-to-ones across the year and it really is a lovely, lovely program to be part of and I'm really enjoying those relationships with people. So if it is your time and you're ready for the next step and needing someone to help you to get there then please do bear this in mind. And there's also the free psychology success guide which you can get by going to my website www.aspiring-psychital.com.uk Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton.
没有最低期限。如果你准备好接受更深入的指导，还有“准备好崛起”（Ready to Rise）项目，你可以和我一起加入一整年，一年内你会获得12次一对一的辅导，这是一个非常棒的项目，我真的很享受与人们建立的这些关系。所以如果现在是你的时间，你准备好迈出下一步，需要有人帮助你实现目标，请务必记住这一点。此外，还有免费的心理学成功指南，你可以通过访问我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 获取。你好，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。
I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was, and using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been
我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，以帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多反思。它还有助于将事情放在正确的角度，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣是每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心，每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力，
such a pleasure, I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真是一种享受，我几乎不舍得读完。这一期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。